they should take like [ __ ] you know
like they do like a mold they should do
a mold of your junk custom they should
write tell me that groupie uses like a
mold of like all the rock stars dicks oh
yeah seem like a fleshlight for porn
stars yeah that so they would like
that's secure yeah and I just yeah I get
I get weirded out by yeah I get weirded
out by that [ __ ] flashlights yeah like
what's this the non-human element in
that gay you want to [ __ ] this thing
that isn't alive there's just something
like you know yeah that's just [ __ ]
this is my [ __ ]
it's a rubber version of my [ __ ] oh
yeah oh [ __ ]
I always yeah back in the day when he
had wanted to get porn he had to go into
his store I just thought that stuff
always it just seems serial killer like
body part type dehumanizing yeah it's
very effective though we the fleshlight
was a sponsor for a while when I
remember the days yeah those things were
great I know I'd stopped using them
though even though like I was trying to
try it I had to try it after a while he
did it feel listeners oh yeah that's it
only for the listeners it's very
effective okay so you know about this
what's that it's called a pachinko what
oh Jesus Christ
I mean you it's a hobby how do you not
like become like how does that not do
brain damage - [ __ ] that oh Jesus that's
so disgusting can you know you think
it's bad getting caught jerking off can
you imagine it if you swam in this foot
India's [ __ ] first of all it looks
real enough that you [ __ ] killed
somebody now you're [ __ ] oh my god
you can [ __ ] a whole leg that is crazy
how realistic that looks it looks like
she's hanging from the ceiling do this
even has like the skin of her heel looks
like it's kind of mushy a little bit
right like it's moving around because I
want this site might get a little weird
it's just as you can build your own
mannequin here okay just get the [ __ ]
yeah we are we're like that what are you
doing I'm in synthetics that's what
that's called synthetics oh yeah
parachutes and stuff yeah something like
that something something like that what
is it a everyone our [ __ ] elbow you do
here's my business card
[Laughter]
I don't know that's when that I think
you buy that and a few weeks later you
buy a giant freezer
[Laughter]